in this country we're learning more
about the damaging consequences of
inadequate medical care offered to
minority communities and today we're
focusing on skin care while african
americans make up 13 percent of the u.s
population only 3 percent of
dermatologists nationwide are black and
nearly half of all dermatologists report
feeling their medical training did not
properly prepare them to treat darker
skin which can lead to increased chances
of misdiagnosis or lack of treatment and
that's exactly what happened to one
california man who was misdiagnosed for
years despite seven years of treatments
shane bloomfield's skin discoloration
remained a mystery to multiple
dermatologists so i looked like a crispy
critter
a burn victim
was embarrassed to walk down the hall
his last doctor simply gave up he stood
right in front of me and said i can't
help you anymore there was a you know
hopelessness and then
a little glimmer of anger shane was
finally referred to dr neda ebilic the
director of usc skin of color and
pigmentary disorders program at keck
medicine hi good morning mr broomfield
how are you
so nice to see you right away dr
eberlook recognized shane had something
more commonly found in melanin-rich skin
lichen planets pigmentosis which causes
darkening as well as related scarring
type of hair loss called lichen
planopylaris i think there was just
immediate relief
just to even just have a name to put
towards it like what it actually is that
he has the fact that the two things were
connected which he'd never realized was
possible dr ebelick says at least once a
week she meets with patients who have
been misdiagnosed or under-treated the
more pigment that somebody has
the more it can change the way that a
condition can look what became defined
as classic for any condition became what
we see in lighter skin right but that's
not necessarily classic and darker skin
she now offers a fellowship at her
clinic to provide much needed
perspective for dermatologists in
training many of these conditions even
if they don't kill you they have
profound effects on quality of life
because shane went many years before
being properly diagnosed he may not make
a full recovery however he remains
optimistic i'm confident that we are on
the right track for treatments and that
this will
be reversed i'm still hopeful
we're now joined by dr jenna lester
assistant professor at uc san francisco
and founder and director of its skin and
color skin of color program how you
doing i'm doing well thanks for having
me good morning so nearly half of all
dermatologists felt like they weren't
prepared to treat darker skin how can we
fix this
in my opinion one of the main avenues
for addressing this is addressing the
gaps that exist in our dermatology
education um in a in a paper that i
published in the british journal of
dermatology we found that there's an
over underrepresentation of patients
with dark skin and our common
dermatology teaching textbook so that
means the photos we're using to learn
what different skin conditions look like
are mostly in light skin and this can
lead to misdiagnosis
now only three percent of the eleven
thousand dermatologists are black so
what are some of the barriers that these
dermatologists are facing um the
barriers are numerous one that i want to
highlight is the cost of applying to
become a dermatologist so some analyses
suggest that medical students pay ten
thousand dollars to
even take that first step to become a
dermatologist and this is on top of what
we know to be the median debt that a
graduating medical student has which is
about 170 000
and we know that
that black and brown students
disproportionately shoulder um a
graduate medical education debt and so
this you can imagine how this might be
more challenging for some than others it
has to be frustrating thinking even if i
go in to see somebody i may be
misdiagnosed but your advice to somebody
who is seeking care would be still go
definitely still go ask around
i think word of mouth is really helpful
in finding who who is a great doctor in
general you can ask friends neighbors
your primary care physician have
questions
before you go in because you know that
white coat anxiety can make you forget
everything you came in to talk about
don't be afraid to ask them and don't be
afraid to get a second opinion as well
that's totally normal thing to do if you
want to have more information about the
diagnosis or understand what all your
treatment options are because asking
around and then also maybe finding
another doctor is time and money is
there kind of rules of thumb a person
should ask themselves about whether they
should trust whatever their initial
diagnosis is i think really trusting
your gut your experience in health care
is really important and the comfort that
you feel with a person i think is
something that should should guide how
how you proceed i've dealt with
everything from discoloration even
losing my hair and one of the questions
that i asked over the phone is do you
treat darker skin
and if i get the response that i need
then i know right out the gate that they
have seen people like me with my skin
color which helps me have a little bit
more comfort when i walk through that
door yeah that's i think that's great
advice in in every aspect diversity is
so important
representation exactly for sure dr jenna
lester thank you so much